today the mat well show John Oliver goes
on the attack to defend so-called trans
rights his monologue on the subject is
supposed to be a sort of definitive
takedown of the conservative position
we'll go through it piece by piece today
to see if it lives up to the hype
obviously it doesn't also a panel of
non-binary and trans people on a college
campus discuss my film what is a woman
and the conversation is as great as it
sounds plus colorblind casting is
apparently back in style again as long
as it excludes white people of course in
our daily cancellation outrage and
controversy erupt over my comments about
anime will I backtrack or spitefully
double down on an issue that doesn't
really matter to me one way or another
we'll find out today all of that and
more on the Matt wall show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
decades ago private citizens used to be
largely that private what's changed well
the internet think about everything
you've browsed search for watched or
tweeted now imagine all of that data
being crawled through collected and
aggregated by Third parties into a
permanent public record your record
having your private life exposed for
others to see was once something only
celebrities worried about but in an era
where everyone is online everyone is now
a public figure whether you like it or
not so to keep my data private when I go
online I turn to expressvpn did you know
that there are hundreds of data Brokers
out there whose sole business is to buy
and sell your data the worst part is
that they don't have to tell you who
they're selling it to or even get your
consent one of these data points is your
IP address data Harvesters use your IP
to uniquely identify you and your
location but with expressvpn my
connection gets rerouted through an
encrypted server and my IP address is
then masked every time I turn expressvp
on VPN on I'm given a random IP address
shared by other expressvpn customers
that makes it more difficult for third
parties to identify me and harvest my
data the best part is how easy
expressvpn is to use no matter what
device you're on phone laptop Smart TV
all you have to do is tap one button to
get protected so if like me you believe
that your data is your business secure
yourself with the number one rated VPN
on the market visit expressvpn.com Walsh
and get three extra months for free
that's exp resvpn.com Welsh go to
expressvpn.com Walsh to learn more
all right so last week John Stewart
devoted an episode of his little watched
Apple TV show to the subject of
so-called transgender rights it was his
attempt to hit back against those
transphobic extremists who believe that
human biology exists now Stuart like so
many other aging leftists is a recent
convert to gender ideology sometime in
the last few years he decided that women
could have penises and men can have
babies he didn't explain his conversion
we don't know if there was a road to
Damascus moment wherein a pregnant man
appeared to him and unveiled the secrets
of the universe or if he experienced
some other sort of vision but he did
apologize for his past acknowledgment of
scientific reality he regrets it deeply
and he's pledged to never make the same
mistake again
Stewart's efforts to debunk biology
consisted primarily of him smirking at
clips of people saying Common Sense
things Stewart of course belongs to that
school of political debate which teaches
that a smarmy grin and a laugh track
qualify as a counter-argument he's not
the only one to employ this strategy his
understudy John Oliver who hosts a
slightly more popular but still little
watch to show on HBO has also made a
career out of this same tactic Oliver
has has earned a reputation on the left
for thoroughly demolishing conservative
arguments reputation that is relatively
easy for him to maintain because nobody
actually watches his show to find out if
it's accurate or not if they did they
would see that his manner of demolishing
an argument is to deliver a series of
the most standard and banal left-wing
talking points imaginable couched in
lies and half truths but these rants
apparently still count as an epic
Smackdown because Oliver is extremely
snide I mean even even more snide than
your usual leftist I mean peppers in a
few lame punch lines plenty of vulgarity
and also has a British accent indeed the
tagline of Oliver's Show could be and
for all I know is Last Week Tonight with
John Oliver the same stuff you hear on
MSNBC except British and with the f word
on Sunday Oliver decided to follow his
mentor's lead and bring his brand of
snide propagandizing to the trans debate
he spent 30 minutes addressing what he
describes as quote a tax on transgender
rights and the left ensures us that the
entire segment is a brilliant
breathtaking
bulletproof defense of their position
and a devastating takedown of the other
side
the same was promised of Jon Stewart's
attempt a week prior only to discover
that the devastating takedown was the
rhetorical equivalent of an
over-inflated balloon it only took the
slightest pin prick to burst the whole
thing so does Oliver fare any better
yes they're both named John they're both
wildly overrated they're both
insufferable smug little Muppets who
imagine themselves to be about 65 IQ
points smarter than they really are but
does that mean that they will fail both
of them miserably in their attempts to
engage with critics of gender ideology
well the answer of course is yes but
don't take my word for it I will go
through now
um John Oliver's segment piece by piece
so that you can see for yourself
Oliver Begins by calling out the I don't
know one or two Democrats in the country
who are not yet fully committed members
of the gender ideology cult and we'll
start there as well
there are many on the left who seem at
best reluctant to engage on this issue
and at worst outright hostile to it
either complaining about pronoun police
or arguing that this issue will cost
Democrats elections if you go to the
middle of the country people would say
if your conversation during a
presidential election is about some guy
wearing a dress and whether he she or it
can go to and and go to the locker room
with their daughter that's not a winning
formula for most people wow it Michael
Bloomberg all the way off with that but
also while this fun-sized billionaire is
clearly good at a lot of things like
making money and end of list maybe don't
take advice on a winning formula for
elections from a man who spent over a
billion dollars of his own money to lose
a presidential bid in just 14 weeks
now first of all it is the grammatically
correct gender-neutral pronoun a human
being who is neither male nor female if
such a creature existed which it doesn't
would indeed be an it it is a singular
pronoun whereas they in most cases is a
pronoun that indicates multiple
individuals now is it dehumanizing yes
obviously it is but a person who rejects
their male or female identity has
already dehumanized themselves or itself
to be human is to be male or female
there are no other options if you reject
that then you reject your Humanity you
have dehumanized yourself also as far as
Michael Bloomberg goes Michael Bloomberg
goes yes his presidential campaign was
in abysmal and often hilarious failure
we can agree on that but the list of
things that he's good at actually
extends Beyond simply making money as
Oliver claims here's one other highlight
on uh Michael Bloomberg's resume
when he was mayor of New York the city
was actually livable and ever since far
left or farther left Democrats anyway
took over it has been a dystopian
crime-ridden hellscape and I think
that's worth noting it's also worth
noting that John Oliver is so thoroughly
wrong about everything all the time that
he just forced me to defend Michael
Bloomberg I already feel like I need to
take a shower we've only made it about a
minute through this thing let's keep
going
let's also remember that it's not
actually the left talking about trans
rights non-stop it's Republicans who see
an advantage in demagoguing this issue
and to ignore them doing that is to
allow them to have real calamitous
impacts on people's lives a few years
ago voice profiled a girl named Kai
shapley and just watch how happy she is
talking about her hopes for a future
until she remembers something that
changes her mood mum says I might grow
up to be the president
yeah what would you change about the
world if you were president
are you able to use the girls bathroom
at school
no they just put security guards up
oh I hate that that is brutal it is so
dark it's genuinely hard to watch
agreed John I mean it is brutal and hard
to watch that is a very young boy who
has been convinced by his parents that
he is a girl
not only that but he is being paraded
around on camera and used as a political
prop he has been made not only trans but
into a trans mascot
very dark indeed
now how do I know that the boy is not a
girl well because a girl is a human
female child and that boy is a human
child but is not female he is male he is
a boy if you have some other alternative
definition for the world girl I'd love
to hear it in fact nothing you say on
this subject John no argument you
present no talking point you put forward
has any meaning or any value or any
significance at all if you cannot or
will not Define the words you're using
now here's something else I know about
that boy aside from the fact that he is
one
the other thing I know John is that is
that being a child and being confused
and being raised in an environment which
intentionally Fosters confusion
means that he has no real concept of
what a girl is that means that when he
says I am a girl
statement doesn't mean anything at best
he is trying to express his affinity for
or interest in some of the things that
he Associates with girls the color pink
long hair dolls whatever none of that
actually makes him a girl John and
that's something that he needs an adult
to explain to him unfortunately all the
adults in his life are just as confused
as he is or at least are pretending to
be just like you
jumping ahead a bit Oliver goes after
Abigail schreier who's the author of The
Great Book irreversible damage about the
trans epidemic claiming the minds and
lives of countless adolescent girls but
Oliver sees no issue with millions of
girls suddenly all at once in unison
deciding that they're really boys this
is perfectly normal John Oliver exists
Troy sometimes dresses her argument up
by using the term rapid onset gender
dysphoria which is total it comes from a
study published by a researcher in 2018
hypothesizing that some kids identify as
trans due to peer pressure but it's
worth you knowing that study was based
on a survey of parents not actual trans
kids and in targeted parents from
organizations dedicated to opposing
trans ideology which is instantly
disqualifying it's like citing a study
claiming that all postal workers not
terrifying hell demons sent to attack
your family but then learning that the
researchers only surveyed a collection
of anxious dogs
that's some heavy sampling bias that
clearly skewed your results
and to be very clear there is ample
evidence of gender variance throughout
human history and as far back as
historians have found evidence of trans
people they found trans children as for
the rapid rise in kids identifying as
trans as the writer Julia Serrano has
pointed out when you look at a chart of
left-handedness among Americans over the
20th century you see a massive Spike
when we stopped forcing kids to write
with their right hand and then a plateau
that doesn't mean everyone became
left-handed or that there was a rapid
onset Southport dysphoria it means
people were free to be who they were
okay
all of that is should go without saying
nonsense first of all uh we don't need a
study to tell us that rapid onset gender
dysphoria exists any more than I need to
read a study drawing a link between the
proliferation of fast food and obesity
such studies do exist but people with
functioning brains can draw obvious
common sense conclusions without needing
permission from a research paper to do
it trans identification has risen
20-fold in the youngest generation even
that example he gives of left-handedness
which is a red herring if I've ever seen
one that shows what a six percent rise
over the course of decades we're talking
about 20-fold in the course of a few
years
we went from almost nobody being
confused about their gender to huge
swaths of young people being confused
about their gender
that is rapid
it is gender dysphoria it seems that
calling it rapid onset gender dysphoria
makes a lot of sense
Oliver takes issue with the study uh
that coins this phrase questioning its
credibility on the grounds that the
researchers only surveyed the parents
instead of the quote trans kids
yes because you're not likely to get a
clear or accurate answer if you ask a
child whether they're doing something
because of peer pressure
see the children also aren't fully
cognizant of their own motivations if
you go up to a child and say are you
only doing that because of peer pressure
you're not likely to get a clear answer
because it's a child
as a parent you should be better
equipped to explain your child's
Behavior than your child is himself this
is the Insight that comes with age and
maturity for some of us anyway obviously
not for you John Oliver also says that
the study is unreliable because the
people who conducted it were allegedly
biased
now that may or may not be true I don't
know anything about the study it doesn't
matter to me I don't need the study to
observe what I can clearly see all
around me but then John goes on through
the whole rest of his diatribe to quote
studies and experts who not only have
clear left-wing biases I mean all of
them every single person that he cites
as an authority every single one has a
clear left-wing bias in that very same
clip at the end he cites a left-wing
activist about the about the left-handed
thing
but not only that
not only do most of his authority
figures have left-wing biases they also
have a financial stake in promoting and
defending gender ideology
so he shows no concern for conflicts of
interest in those cases
in fact just like Jon Stewart his entire
defense of the mutilation and castration
of children is that the people making
money off of these procedures think it's
a good idea
that is the entirety of his argument he
has no other argument
as for the quote ample evidence of
gender variance throughout human history
well I went and read the article that he
cites because you know he puts the
quotes up there on the screen and what
you're supposed to do is just see the
quote and then say to yourself well he
had a quote on the screen it must be
true but I actually went and looked at
that National Geographic article and
what I've I found as always is that it
points to examples from history of
spiritual and religious practices
where a man acts out the part of a woman
okay that is not the same as a man
claiming to actually be a woman
it's not even close to the same it's not
even the same sort of thing
unless John you're admitting that
transgenderism today is a religious and
spiritual conviction
because those are all of the historical
comparisons that you are making
for the thousandth time there has never
been ever in history not once not
anywhere
a culture that believed that men could
literally physically be woman women and
vice versa
ours is the only civilization that has
ever believed in pregnant men
there is no precedent for that in
history anywhere
one other point John uh later in the
show
cites the high rates of suicide among
trans kids he says that suicidal
ideation is as high as 57 I believe it
says 57 percent almost 60 percent
for quote unquote trans kids now he
blames this on a lack of affirmation
he says indeed the the consequence of
not affirming trans kids is that uh many
will kill themselves
he also says that the reason there were
not millions of trans kids historically
is that they were not free to be who
they effing were
well according to him then
as I've pointed out many times
there should be historically evidence of
millions and millions and millions of
kids all over the world every year for
thousands of years killing themselves
that's how you connect those dots
High rates of suicide if you don't
affirm there were millions and millions
of trans people through history that
were not Affirmed
and yet no such evidence exists it
didn't happen
kids only started killing themselves in
significant numbers now
in modern times in correlation with the
rise in trans identifications so what
does that tell you John
can you turn the laugh track down for a
moment and think clearly about this it's
not very hard to connect the dots
we'll play one more clip Oliver
eventually gets around to offering a
defense of so-called gender affirming
care and let's hear what that sounds
like
at the onset of puberty and Adolescent
and their family might consider puberty
blockers hormones that delay puberty and
importantly if that treatment is
suspended then puberty will resume
meaning this is reversible think of it
like a pause button the thing you can't
do easily on the HBO Max app now the
next potential medical intervention is
usually hormone therapy which boosts
levels of testosterone or estrogen
opponents of gender affirming care make
a lot of alarmist claims about hormone
therapy from saying that it's
experimental which it is not to arguing
that it sterilizes people and look for
some in specific situations there can be
risks to fertility but for others the
effect is anticipated to be reversible
if the medication is discontinued but
there is definitely an informed decision
to be made there you will notice that
none of what I've mentioned so far is
surgery but when it does come to that
some teens may be eligible for instance
for Top surgery or chest masculinization
but you should know not only is that
pretty rare it like all of this would
only happen after a team of medical
professionals discussed all of its risks
and benefits with their patient and
their patient's parent or Guardian all
of whom would have to sign off it is a
long involved process even before you
get to the fact that it's also
incredibly expensive which is why
working-class families families of color
and people with less resources are way
less able to access it basically no kid
is casually dropping into an operating
room because they just decided to get
their uterus removed with impulsive
recklessness normally associated with
getting bangs because that is I
absolutely ridiculous thing to say
yes it is a ridiculous thing to say John
which is why nobody is saying it you
have very impressively torched a straw
man but let's get back to the reality
first John claims that puberty blockers
are totally reversible and merely put a
pause on puberty this is simply a lie
I'm not going to speculate about whether
John Oliver is smart enough to know that
it's a lie everything he says can be
explained either by his idiocy or his
utter lack of Integrity but it's
impossible to know which aspect of his
personality is flaring up at any given
moment what we can say is that the NHS
used to claim that puberty blockers are
reversible they had it on their website
if you go to the website now it's not
there they removed that claim from their
website and they now admit that in fact
they don't really know anything about
the long-term effects of these drugs on
kids why don't they know well because
we've never put millions of physically
healthy kids on this kind of drug regime
before so we don't know there's no way
to know for certain what the long-term
effects are anyone who claims they know
is lying
these kids are being experimented on we
don't yet have the full results of the
experiment it is ongoing right now
yet Common Sense would tell us that all
drugs have side effects especially those
that intentionally interfere with the
natural physical development during
childhood
you cannot pause the human body like you
pause a television John which by the way
it's not that hard to figure out how to
pause uh on HBO Max I'm not even sure
what you're talking about this is not
science fiction okay human being human
bodies can't just hang out in a state of
suspended animation without consequence
that's not how it works
Oliver then acknowledges that um
hormone therapy for children does
sterilize them but he just kind of hand
waves it away and assures us that for
some uh sure there are kids that are
being sterilized but but for some the
effects of the drugs are anticipated to
be reversible if the medication is
discontinued in time that has a lot of
qualifiers
a lot of qualifiers attached to that
sentence in other words yes it
permanently damages a child's body
permanently sterilizes them but that's
okay because sometimes potentially maybe
it won't harm them as much if they stop
it before the worst side effects set in
in other words Oliver knows that the
drugs harm kids but he doesn't care
he takes the same approach to mutilation
surgeries on minors assuring us that
there are no genital surgeries happening
to kids under the age of 18 which is
just a lie and then he also says that
chest masculinization otherwise known as
double mastectomy only happens if all
the people who will make money on the
procedure say that it should happen
this is the best defense that Oliver can
offer
it's not only dishonest and deceptive
and strikingly stupid but also morally
horrifying
and notice the two questions that Oliver
avoids
he never grapples with the issue of
consent
can a child under the age of 18 actually
consent to any of this
can a 14 year old consent to taking a
drug that will likely sterilize him can
a 15 year old girl consent to having her
breasts removed
Oliver spends 30 minutes dancing around
the subject but never once offers his
own theory of consent of course he
doesn't because he doesn't want to be on
the record arguing that a 14 year old
can consent because he knows how
horrifying and creepy and disturbing
that would sound
but he also doesn't want to be on the
record acknowledging that these things
are happening to kids without their
consent
the question of consent presents an
impossible problem for his side of the
argument and he knows it so he ignores
it
which makes literally everything he says
on the subject of quote gender affirming
care for minors irrelevant as he is
Slithering around and avoiding one of
our primary and most fundamental
objections to it
but
there's an even more fundamental
objection which he also avoids
and that is this
it is not true that a boy can be a girl
or a girl can be a boy
it is not true that gender is fluid
gender ideology is false it does not
reflect the actual reality that we find
ourselves situated in
John Oliver like every other
propagandist on that side simply leaps
over this point but you can't leap over
it we're not challenging your views
simply on the basis that it causes harm
to people though that is one of our most
important objections we are challenging
its factual validity
okay we are saying that it is not true
and so if you have any hope of even
coming close to debunking any of our
arguments you must begin by defending
the fundamental proposition that a male
can be a woman and a female can be a man
if you skip that question
then you skip the whole debate John
just as people skip your show on HBO Max
because unlike you apparently they're
smart enough to work a remote
the pause button is right there in the
middle for future reference
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know one of the great things about
Helix is they have several different
mattress models to choose from they have
soft medium firm mattresses mattress is
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot mattress is great for spinal
alignment to prevent morning aches and
pains and even a helix plus size
mattress for uh plus size sleepers which
is especially important to me they also
have a sleep quiz that matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress because why would you
buy a mattress made for someone else if
you're looking for a mattress take the
quiz order the mattress that you're a
match to and wait for the delivery your
mattress will come right to your door
for free you don't ever need to go to a
mattress store again couple couples
fight about a lot of things I think your
mattress doesn't need to be one of those
things so sit down with your wife or
husband go to helixsleep.com Walsh take
their two minute sleep quiz and find the
perfect mattress for you and your spouse
they have a 10 year warranty and you get
to try it out for a hundred nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but trust me
you will so for a limited time Helix is
offering up to 350 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners this is the best offer yet so
hurry over to Helix sleep.com slash
Welsh
all right I want to start with this uh
because this just it it makes me happy I
was very annoyed to start the show which
is why I went on for if I start the show
annoyed then I'm going to go on for 25
minutes
um but this this I this I like so yaf
has this video that they posted
yesterday there was a panel discussion
at St Louis University
um slew as they uh apparently call it
and now you may remember St Louis
University because that's where I gave a
speech
last spring and there were huge protests
outside and all the rest of they really
didn't want me there and um
they've kind of been from what I
understand ever since my appearance
there they've really been grappling with
the fact that I was allowed to be there
and and the the trauma from my visit
still has not worn off I mean people are
still devastated and traumatized by it
so yesterday at St Louis University they
had a panel discussion featuring trans
and quote quote-unquote non-binary
people and during this discussion a line
was uttered that is perhaps in my
opinion
the greatest thing ever said during a
panel discussion though I am biased and
you'll see why let's watch this
subject matter expert or they could be
even like pro-trans but it was like it
was a trap he was going to get you into
that room and then he was going to say a
bunch of transphobic stuff because I
can't stop the map well she's like you
can't stop now I think you can only pour
in as much new information other people
that's true okay can we start just pause
there for a second
you can't stop the Matt Walsh what makes
that so good if you just said you can't
stop Matt Walsh that would be great but
he said you can't stop the Matt Walton
for some reason the the in that sentence
makes it so much better you can't stop
the mouse we need to get that on a
t-shirt that needs to be in the merch
store tomorrow
you can't stop the Matt Walsh and in
fact fact check true fact Checkers have
looked into that claim and have found
that it is actually accurate you can't
stop them at Walsh I also want to
mention but right before that it's the
other person is uh I assume talking
about what is a woman
and says that well uh we laid a trap and
got people in the room and started
saying a bunch of transphobic stuff
well anyone who's watched the film uh
knows that that's
nonsense I I didn't all I said to them I
asked questions I didn't present any
arguments at all actually to any of
these people
um so saying transphobic stuff
apparently equals asking questions
and all of the questions of course we
ask in the film all really just boiled
down to
um what are you saying so like they're
saying things and then all of my
questions really come down to what is
what does that mean what is it what what
you're telling me right now explain what
that means I'm trying to understand it I
want to understand it
that's transphobic
uh I don't know what else is in this
clip but we've already heard the best of
it but let's let's play a little bit
more
we're talking about people
um who
no matter what it is they think that
they know or what it is that they're
ignorant about
um that ignorance or that lack of
information or the misinformation is
leading them to a place where they are
afraid of trans people because they're
afraid of what trans people existing
might mean for them and then and
therefore with you whether the woman you
know as far as trans experience goals
what does it mean for you know assistant
women
and the turfs and everything because a
lot of the times really quickly uh I
mean it's an acronym for Trans exclusive
radical feminism t-e-r-s so feminist
rule in their plate for feminism will
exclude transpose at best and at worst
we like transpose or impeding on like
women's CIS women's safety or it would
be a situation of you being intimidated
by my look and the fact that I have a
nice physique it's just for me a lot of
the times I know from my personal
experience right okay
let's pause it or don't pause it stop it
all together
yeah oh that explains right that's um
that is how you explain these people are
so good at lying to themselves and
telling themselves the most flattering
lives they possibly can
so according to this person all of our
objections to uh gender ideology all
boil down to the fact that we're
intimidated
we're intimidated by
is was that a trans was that a trans
person his looks
that's you're I'm so good looking that's
what uh you're just intimidated by that
no the fear
actually see the fear is not on our end
this is what they love to do they love
to accuse us of where we're afraid of
trans people we're
we're just trembling in fear
so where are the ones afraid meanwhile
if I go to a college campus
you you're you are outside screaming
with tears streaming down your face
you don't even want me to show up you're
trying to stop me from even being there
and I'm the one afraid I am trying to go
to a place and you are saying you don't
even want me in your physical vicinity
I'm afraid
no you're afraid you're terrified
you're terrified of me
maybe it's because I'm good looking
maybe that's also part of the part of
the part of what's going on you know
going into this
you want to date me I don't know
but what I certainly know is that you're
afraid of the questions you're afraid of
the ideas
so all of the you know trying to shut
down conversation shut down discussion
all of that happens on the left
when it comes to gender ideology
on the right we're not doing any of that
now we will say that uh we don't want
discussion of this in like a
kindergarten classroom
you know why because that's not a
discussion that's indoctrination the
kindergartners that are sitting there
they're not going to be equipped to
respond and ask skeptical questions and
debate you which is why you want to
relegate these conversations to those
kinds of environments where you're
talking to people who are not able to
contradict you
so yeah you want to bring gender
ideology up in an environment where you
know no one's going to ask any skeptical
questions no one's going to make you
explain yourself
um there's not going to be any debate
whatsoever
as far as an actual discussion it's like
we're the ones trying to engage you in
that
all right
so here's another
clip that I wanted to play for you uh
Colin Wright has this on on Twitter he
posted this it says in Matt Walsh's
documentary he confronted surgeon Marcy
Bowers about The Logical parallels
between surgery Justified on the basis
of gender dysphoria versus body
Integrity disorder
our body Integrity dysphoria
um Bowers dismissed the latter claim as
kooky
but W pass standards of Care Now include
bid body Integrity Disorder so then he's
got this video which contrasts that
scene in the film with what a presenter
at wpath now says about this subject
and by the way Marcy Bowers is the
incoming president of wpeth I think is
now officially the the president
so
you know I was told that comparing these
two things just totally off the wall you
can't do that
um and yet here's what they said at
wpath and this was just a few weeks ago
let's watch the clip
as far as you ever heard of people in
the trans abled Community these are
people who are physically able-bodied
but feel like they should be disabled or
identified as such there are others who
have a feeling that their genitals are
not a part of their proper part of their
body body Integrity dysphoria for
example a man who has two arms but feels
like he should have one if if a man in
this kind of marginalized Community was
went to the doctor and said I want to
have
my arm cut off
do you think that that doesn't have
anything to do with gender identity uh
this is in the soc-8 it's also an icd-11
it's classification 621 or 6c21 uh so
it's it's there in the ICD as well as
the standards of care
well it's uh some someone's
someone's self-identity that sounds
that's someone who has a um a and I'll
accept it as a mental diagnosis a
psychiatric condition I don't even
pretend to know what abdomenophilia is
all about but somehow it's the idea that
you and you know you're fascinated or
Charmed by having a limb or part of a
limb missing okay I would say that's
uh pardon my non-medical language kooky
they desire to be not male to be
emasculated but don't want to be female
either
they have a male to eunuch gender
dysphoria now part of the soc-8
you don't see any
you think this is totally irrelevant
yeah
but I am the first trans feminine person
to be elected president of wpath and
it's 43 years
there you go so I went from uh we did an
interview with Bowers
I don't know in September
and so in less than a year you know
that's that's how quickly we're on this
uh slippery slope here is it it took
less than a year for that to go from
kooky irrelevant and kooky to oh yeah
totally legitimate that's uh it's all
part of the same It's all under the same
umbrella now they admit
that if you want to because of course it
is of course it is
if we're supposed to take someone's
self-identity seriously as I try to
explain ever taking someone's
self-identity seriously it's how they
self-identify it's their truth
if that's the precedent we're setting
then on what basis can we tell someone
that they're wrong if someone identifies
as disabled they want to have their leg
chopped off
and they say that you know they feel
like that's how they're supposed to be
they're supposed to only have one leg
it doesn't make any sense what do you
mean you're supposed to have one leg
well it makes as much sense at least
as a man saying he's supposed to be a
woman
it actually makes more sense see that's
the thing it's so that's one of the
problems with the slippery slope and I I
use the term too but it's not exactly
accurate because it makes it sound like
there's this kind of logical progression
or regression in this case where we go
from uh a you know one thing to a to a
slightly more extreme thing to slightly
more extreme on down the way but
oftentimes what you find is that we go
directly to the most extreme thing and
then we kind of circle back and cover
all the bases that we skipped
so the legitimizing body Integrity
disorder legitimizing someone's claim
that they're supposed to have uh one leg
or they're supposed to be a eunuch that
is crazy
okay that is perverse and insane but it
is
it still makes
more sense
than the claim that a man is supposed to
be a woman
makes more sense
because it is at least you know it's
it's if you're if you have two legs as a
man you can become a one-legged man that
is possible you that's that is a
possible thing that can happen it
happens to many men
um whereas there is nothing if you're a
man that could ever make you a woman
it's impossible it is impossibility
so it's the difference between
identifying it's the difference between
identifying some identifying as
something that is possible
versus identifying as something that is
impossible
so we went to the most extreme thing
and now everything else that happens
that we consider to be sort of uh down
the slippery slope is actually further
up the slippery slope not further down
all right we got to do sort of an
abbreviated five headlines because I
spent so much time on John Oliver but
we've got another John that's causing a
problem today I also wanted to mention
this this is from The Daily Mail it says
John Leguizamo it's not been a great
couple of weeks for John's John
Leguizamo has slammed the all-white cast
of Super Mario Brothers uh the new film
that's coming out and the lack of latinx
leads on uh he said this on Saturday the
actor 62 who played Luigi in the 1993
live action film critique the casting
choices as the film sees Chris Pratt
take on the iconic role of the Italian
plumber Mario following the release of
the first trailer for the upcoming film
John voiced his concerns while praising
the groundbreaking colorblind casting of
the original taking to Twitter he said
quote so glad Super Mario Bros is
getting a reboot obviously it's iconic
but too bad they went all white no
latinx in the leads groundbreaking
colorblind casting in the original plus
I'm the only one who knows how to make
this movie work script wise
well tinks is a term that is intended to
be gender neutral okay Bubba we know
that he attached three screenshots of
himself as Luigi and Bob Hoskins Who
played Mario from the 1993 film in the
photo caption he wrote apologize to this
movie right now
okay so his real problem is that just
he's not being cast in the film
and he has he's somehow convinced
himself
that the original Super Mario Brothers
film was some sort of iconic Masterpiece
and he made the script work
now this this like nothing that can make
the script work in that film or in this
one by the way
I mean it is a a film based on a video
game
about Italian plumbers who are in some
sort of hallucinogenic State and have
magical powers and are fighting
oversized turtles so like there's really
nothing that can happen that can make
that script make any sense at all
but he seems to imagine that that's what
he did
but here's here's the real point about
this
this just shows are these it's just the
the
it's fruitless and helpless to point out
the hypocrisy but I still I can't help
but do it because John Luke was
Leguizamo
just a few weeks ago
was taking issue with the casting of
James Franco as Fidel Castro and his
issue then he called for a boycott of
the upcoming Fidel Castro biopic which
is by the way I'll be boycotting it just
uh by default because I have no interest
in watching a biopic about Fidel Castro
that's not his problem with it and he
agrees with Fidel Castro politically but
he doesn't want to see Fidel Castro
besmirched and degraded by having a
white guy betray him he said that there
should be there should be quote latinx
person portraying Fidel Castro so that
that was his criticism for the Castro
film is that there shouldn't be a white
guy because you need to make the
ethnicities accurate
need to reflect you know the character
they're portraying
but then on this one he has the exact
opposite criticism
so his problem with Fidel Castro film is
that they did colorblind casting his
problem for Mario is that it's is that
it's not colorblind casting
so what is his real issue here his real
issue is just with hiring white people
to act in films that's it he just
doesn't like seeing white people in
films because he is a raging despicable
racist
all right
let's get now to the comment section
October is cyber security awareness
month and right now is the perfect time
to ensure you're doing everything you
can to stay safe online be cyber smart
by taking these basic steps to help keep
you and your family protected from
identity theft scams and other online
dangers that is use strong passwords set
up multi-factor authentication on
authentication on your accounts and
regularly update the software on your
device as well it's so important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives every day
we put our information at risk on the
internet in an instant a cyber criminal
could harm what's yours your finances
your credit everything good thing
there's LifeLock LifeLock helps to
detect a wide range of identity threats
like if your social security number is
for sale on the dark web if they detect
your information they will send you an
alert listen nobody can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can keep what's yours yours with
Lifelock Identity Theft Protection join
now Now's the Time to do it save up to
25 off your first year at lifelock.com
Walsh that's lifelock.com com Walsh for
25 percent off
granny Holmes referring to these awoke
cosmetic and Beauty companies that we
talked about to start the show yesterday
says they're not marketing to women Matt
they're marketing to men who have to buy
a lot of makeup because they have to
cake on so much you're right it is a
Minstrel show
by the way I have to say I wish I could
take credit for this but I saw somebody
on Twitter I don't remember who but
someone on Twitter yesterday said that
uh you know these this these this woman
face performance of men dressing up like
like women I call it a Minstrel show but
the better term for it would be
menstrual show and
that is brilliant I I so wish that I had
thought of it that I could steal it but
I can in good conscious because it's so
good but I will be using it from now on
so it is a menstrual show
um now you say that they're marketing to
men and not to women but that's why
you're wrong see that's that's the point
that's what makes all of this all the
more outrageous and absurd is that they
are still marketing to women
you know Ulta beauty and and uh Revlon
and you know Cover Girl and all the rest
of them that have bought into this um
to what they called yesterday the
degenderization they are still even
though they're using male mascots now
and they're having they're bringing men
in to pontificate about the beauty of
girlhood quote unquote
they are still marketing to women
if they didn't have women customers they
would all go under there are not enough
gender-bending males out there to keep
any of these makeup companies in
business and there never will be there
never will be
and they know that
so it's not just that they're core
customer base
consists of women but that's still
pretty much in effect their only
customer base
and yet
they they are intentionally alienating
and degrading and demeaning
their customer base
for the sake of scoring woke points
and I don't know if it's so much that
they are willing to lose money I think
it's more that they're confident they
won't
it's not going to gain them anything but
they figure well we convert your signal
to the woke left and earn some points
that way and we can keep the Pitchfork
mob from coming after us
um but you know the customers will just
deal with it even if they don't like it
they'll still buy from us
and that's where it's up to the
customers to prove them wrong
all right Aaron says I feel like there's
a chance Matt will complain so much
about watching the WNBA game then when
he gets there he'll have an amazing time
and become a lifelong fan uh I would not
put any money on that bet Aaron
now
you know I granted
like almost every other American I've
never watched a WNBA game so I guess I
can't say for sure that I won't enjoy it
but I
I hope you don't put too much money on
that on that's a wager
Tom says I'm a 70 kilogram person and it
makes me so angry that I'd have to pay
extra for bags but a 120 kilogram person
is allowed the same weight of bags as I
am and is allowed to take over my
personal space I agree with you but
please stop using those fake British
measuring units okay they're called
pounds I don't know what this kilogram
stuff is this is America we speak
American here
Tom
uh Lagoon JL says Matt I feel a trend
coming along where you tend to agree to
terms not wholeheartedly thinking about
the consequences for example the
interpretive dance Fiasco I still feel
cheated and now the WNBA bet the old
saying Rings true don't let your mouth
write checks that your ass can't cash uh
have fun at the game still love and
honor you SBG for life
yeah that's not a trend that's
developing or coming on that is the
story of my life I will basically agree
to anything if it's more than one week
away because if it's more than one week
in the future I'll just agree to it
somebody could come up to me and say hey
Matt
in two months I was wondering if you
want me to come and uh shoot you
directly in the head and I would just
absent-mindedly look up and say uh two
months yeah sure go ahead but just put
it on my Google Calendar and I'll yeah
it's fine yeah okay
the future isn't real to me I don't know
it's it's the curse of the
procrastinator this is how we work like
we work in the present in the future
it's an it's an abstraction it's an idea
that's all time is a flat circle
redneck Roy says if Matt tells his wife
he's leaving for the night for a WNBA
game she's going to think he's having an
affair uh in my case no because she's
you my wife is used to me doing totally
bizarre things
that involved me leaving the house
sometimes for extended periods of time I
mean keep in mind I had to have the
conversation with my wife last year at
some point that I want to go to a third
world country
um on a 26-hour plane ride to go talk to
primitive tribesmen about transgenderism
like that's that's a conversation I had
to Broach with her and it's it's a it's
a conversation that we had so
that's what she's uh those are the kinds
of ideas she's used to hearing from me
and finally forklift certified gentleman
says Bubba Wallace acts like someone
who's named Bubba
I totally disagree and that's actually
one of my biggest problems with Bubba
Wallace is that I think he's a disgrace
to the name Bubba I don't when I think
of Bubba I don't think of
this whiny
attention starved guy who's also always
complaining about being a victim like
when you think of a Bubba you think of
someone who sees a garage door pull
and collapses onto the ground in a fetal
position and starts weeping
that's what you think of when you when
you hear the name Bubba
not me that's uh
don't try to put that on all Bubbas
everywhere that is not fair
well if you know me you know how much I
love Halloween and how excited I am to
dress up for the holiday
um now I may have to settle for a
run-of-the-mill superhero costume that's
you know that's my default every year
just pull out the Batman costume but
there's still hope for you this year I
will be going as my favorite anime
character but this Halloween you could
be the star of the year's breakout hit
documentary what is a woman that's right
you can head over to dailywire.com shop
and check out my collection to get your
very own Matt Walsh Halloween costume as
you know they did all this without my
consent or approval and they have put my
likeness out there and my very identity
is now being appropriated as a costume
and that's okay because we're making
some money off of it I have principles
after all so be sure to post on social
media and tag me in the daily wire to
show off your costume you might even
make it on the show remember not all
heroes wear capes this one wears a
sandwich board also the daily wire is
hiring oh come on
the daily wire is hiring a senior vice
president of marketing analytics data
and operations wow that's a lot of
responsibility
I'm told that this is a high profile
executive role with paid relocation to
Nashville this innovator will Design
hire and oversee a world-class marketing
data analytics team that has built atop
the marketing data stack from CRM
platforms to multi-touch attribution
tools
to propensity targeting models
this leader will for example study which
daily wire shows and films most interest
the fans and also which daily wire host
is the most annoying so if you
understand what a full marketing data
and analytics stack is head over to
dailywire.com careers now to apply
please dear God someone just apply for
this
damn job
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
yesterday on the show I briefly
mentioned a controversy that had at the
time only recently started simmering it
was a controversy surrounding comments
made by The Humble host of this very
podcast and if you've been paying
attention at all you know that when my
comments spark controversy it's always
because I have broached a very important
subject and raised an issue of urgent
National importance such as of course
the backlash over my advocacy for the
rights of translucent mermaids the topic
this time around isn't quite that
serious but but almost
so
as I detailed yesterday during an
all-access live chat this past Friday
I was asked to give my opinion on the
subject of anime
and I spent about 35 seconds on the
subject in which I stated that from my
vantage point anime is satanic now I
acknowledge that I have no argument to
support that view I have no perhaps
reason or justification for it it is
rather as the kids say A vibe anime has
a satanic Vibe that's all have I ever
seen anime
do I even know exactly what anime is
these questions aren't relevant all that
matters is that as I said in response to
a live question someone asked anime is
the work of the devil that's that's my
truth
that I live in every day now there are
those there are some who might assume
that
this comment was simply a half-assed off
the cuff joke about cartoons and that's
all now there are some who might have
observe that I've also argued for
cyclists to be imprisoned I've said that
people who leave their shopping carts in
the parking lot are morally equivalent
to serial killers and should be executed
on the spot I've called for legislation
out long small talk and elevators and
the use of emojis by males over the age
of 18. I even spent three months on this
show attacking my own employer over his
refusal to give me a giant stuffed
walrus
so you might assume that my theories
about anime's satanic Origins
should be taken in the same Spirit as
all those other sorts of comments
and you're right because I'm totally
serious about all of it
it's good then that social media took it
with the seriousness that it was
intended I was one of the top trending
subjects on Twitter Nationwide yesterday
again this time due to my controversial
stance on anime a great mini accounts
with anime avatars expressed their hurt
and anger over my opinion leading me to
believe that maybe I was wrong about
anime causing demonic possession maybe
it actually just causes you to become an
extremely whiny dork that's another
theory meanwhile the news media jumped
into action my randomly muttered hot
take about anime made it into the
headlines of several major news outlets
Yahoo news reports daily wire troll Matt
Walsh denounces anime as satanic though
he doesn't know why
denounces I denounced it
mediaite says Matt Walsh declares anime
satanic but admits he's not sure why
the independent says Matt Walsh says he
thinks all anime is satanic and adults
shouldn't be watching cartoons
Newsweek takes a slightly different
angle they say daily wire host who
called anime satanic blasted by real
satanists
oh well if real satanists are angry
about it then
I guess I'm more right than I ever
realized
so I can now with more confidence than
ever say that that I stand by my
comments obviously
um anime is satanic
and it leads to demonic possession in
upwards of 87 percent of cases studies
show
recent reports suggest that hat listen
to this listen to this
half of all Pokemon fans will become
Mass murderers
the other half will also become Mass
murderers
if any of my critics had ever studied
history they would know that Adolf
Hitler Genghis Khan Caligula all were
anime fans or would have been if it
existed in fact and this statistic is
the most shocking of all
I want you to listen closely to this
nearly 100 percent of all violent
criminals in the country
have seen Dragon Ball Z
or have heard of it
or know someone who has seen or heard of
it
the numbers speak for themselves
though In fairness there is perhaps no
reason to single out Japanese animation
in this way sure it's especially weird
and unsettling but it's from Japan after
all so what do you expect really though
every cartoon is satanic that's the only
clarification all that I'll offer here
every cartoonist satanic look at PAW
Patrol for example
talking dogs with dead lifeless eyes who
engage in all manner of sorcery
the whole town of Adventure Bay cowers
in fear under the tyrannical regime of
these beasts even the mayor who's really
a figurehead obeys their every whim
there are no checks and balances in this
system
the PAW Patrol are given free reign to
be judged jury and potentially
executioners
now when you consider that scripture
often uses wolves to symbolize the
forces of evil you begin to see in the
PAW Patrol sort of perverse satanic
fable
and this is still one of the Tamer shows
what about Coco melon a bizarre deranged
plotless hypnotic spectacle which places
toddlers into an insensible trance-like
state where they mutter incantations
summoning dark Forces that they don't
understand
these are yet more cartoon related
opinions that I am seriously stating in
which I hope will be taken as seriously
as I mean them
of course hypothetically
as a thought experiment if you were to
pretend for a moment that with my
Infamous anime commentary I was actually
just making a random spur of the moment
joke about a subject that I really don't
care about at all and that Media Matters
is creating a controversy over something
that I forgot I even said 45 seconds
after I said it
then in this alternate universe one
might make the following observation
it is sad that we live in a culture
where you can't speak off the cuff or
offer an opinion even ironically or
ingest or only half seriously without it
being clipped and isolated and turned
without your consent into your Die Hard
Mantra or fundamental belief system I
had people yesterday demanding to know
why I've chosen to die on this hill why
am I ranting about an anime why do I
care so much about what other people
choose to watch well am I dying on a
hill by making a flippant hyperbolic
remark on a subject that someone else
asked me about
is literally everything you say a hill
you're dying on
Are you seriously pretending that you
never exaggerate or engage in hyperbole
or say something outrageous for comedic
effect are you pretending that you've
never articulated an edgy or weird
opinion maybe seriously maybe as a joke
maybe as some mixture of the two are you
pretending that you don't understand
these methods of human communication
that are utterly commonplace and a
feature of nearly every conversation
you've ever had in your life
yes you are pretending that you are
pretending so you can score whatever
point you think you're scoring here and
the effect over time is that authentic
conversation is stifled and people feel
as though they have to constantly speak
like they're reading from a press
release written by a corporate PR firm
the color and flavor of human
conversation the stuff that makes it fun
and interesting just kind of Fades away
these are all things that you might say
if you believe that I was not being
totally serious when I declared all
animation made in Japan satanic
but again I was serious
I am serious about everything
if I was joking I would laugh
deadpan humor has never been my thing as
you well know
and that is why
in the end
with all that said anime is still
canceled
and cast back down into the fiery hell
Flames from whence it came
that'll do it for this portion of the
shows and move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not
talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
all right
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]